love this man love everything about him
he's one of the all-time greats in
playing basketball collegiately he's on
the nba 75th all-time 5th 75th
anniversary all-time team and he's part
of westwood one's coverage of the
national championship game tonight he is
the great bill walton how are you bill
championship day
yeah
this is what we live for the moment of
truth but right now we're the moment
before the moment of truth new orleans
louisiana yeah wow history the past the
present the future the war of 1812 the
synergies
unc north carolina kansas dean smith
larry brown roy williams danny manning
the 57 undefeated championship team from
north carolina that beat kansas by one
in that game that was wilt oh my gosh
unc that year in 57 i was four
the
that team was the second of seven
undefeated teams in the history of
college basketball coached by frank
maguire they beat dick harp that day
kansas 10 championship games in their
illustrious history north carolina 12
ucla still has the record here but wow
what a weekend here in new orleans
starting off friday night with the hall
of fame dinner in the french quarter all
the new people going in headlined by
manu yeah the guy that could catch a bat
standing still
and then stanford and yukon women what a
game uconn was just brilliant stanford
could not break free offensively and
yukon won convincingly before getting
just trounced as everybody did this year
by south carolina congratulations once
again to dawn staley and then saturday
night
oh my gosh the game of forever
then we didn't even go to bed we got up
sunday and went to the naismith awards
over at the world war ii museum just a
few blocks from where we are at our
wonderful hotel walker kessler he wins
the defensive player of the year ed
cooley providence coach of the year and
a remarkable speech beth bass was
honored for women's basketball
contributions
oscar sheebway he was a player of the
year it was absolutely fantastic john
calipari always there for his players
just a spectacular human being getting
it done but the show was just overrun by
jim nance and his speech please google
that speech youtube that speak gymnast
speech at the naysmith awards sunday
morning
i
study speakers i study greatness this
was one of the greatest moments of my
life and then we had the westwood one
dinner last night in the french quarter
that was over the top
and then today i'm on the rich eisen
show i'm having lunch with bob pettit
and then the game tonight
one one
one moment of sadness though before we
get going here sure
is that one of my coaches jean shu the
legend he passed away today at 93 oh i
didn't know that say a prayer light a
candle and live your life and our lives
in tribute and honor to the great gene
shu but
wow what a game on saturday night it
sure was bill i mean that was truly
unbelievable it's so rare that a game
that's so looked forward to and so hyped
lives up to it and surpasses it um what
do you think was the difference in that
game on saturday night what do you think
games are won and lost when your best
players outplay their best players and
the game that caleb love had the same
game that he had against ucla
uh caleb love is one of those really
special dudes and i love jamba juice and
my favorite jamba juice is chocolate
peanut butter love so every time i see
caleb love i just think of how happy
chocolate peanut butter love makes me
and his ability to just score i mean
that ultimately you know offense wins
and you know the greatest offensive
players the guys who can just score when
the defense is set and dug in you know
that's kareem and that's lebron that's
michael jordan that's larry bird and
that's
the guys who have written the history of
this game and so now
you know you've got this guy caleb loved
and i love underdogs
this game this was a movie this whole
scene and and
the
the
villanova in kansas game i mean it
really never
became a game kansas just played perfect
they've been playing perfect ever since
the halftime of the miami game in the
regional finals and you know they will
be a a huge force to be reckoned with
tonight but was talking about saturday
night man that game the fans i was
sitting right in the corner of the court
just down the way from uh where our
westwood one broadcast position is
and i you know i'm the i'm the prop i'm
the studio guys
bridge shows and everything so i i got
this fantastic seat and then the game is
right there and then just at one o'clock
for me
is that north carolina band at 2 30 is
the north carolina student section and
then directly behind me at six
on the clock is the north carolina fan
section with the alumni and the sponsors
and the boosters and all the parents and
everything and it was just incredible
and the you know there there's so much
animosity there's so much tension and
tenacity and all the different things
that go into great athletic competition
and that's just between the fans and so
all this this the whole script of how
this movie was going to be written you
know
off into the sunset on this big white
horse mescalido and the trap and the
incredible uh
story lines of them coming and and then
losing and him saying it's unacceptable
we're not done yet and they're coming
back and they're playing great and they
got all the best players and then
leaky black
chocolate peanut butter love rj davis
the brady man is i mean brady medic
they're going to name a band after the
same way that pearl jam named themselves
mookie blaylock at the beginning
and then armando baker armando baycott
who's such a wonderful player and you
know duke has all the all the stars all
the hype all the publicity and all of
everything and they've got coach k here
and then north carolina they got hubert
davis who a significant number of people
there in north carolina did not want
hubert davis to be the coach for
whatever reasons and then all of a
sudden he becomes the coach they
struggle mightily they get blown out
early by kentucky in the season they're
not playing well but then they find a
way and you got armando because who's
playing fantastic setting records out
there and then he gets hurt with
four or five minutes to go and then he
fouls out he comes back from the dead i
mean this was dan pastorini on steroids
here and so it's all happening in a
brilliant scene and this story is all
right there and every time some team
scores you think the game is over and
then 30 seconds later it switches and
it's just back and forth and back and
forth and in in the superdome which is
like this monstrous place you know
you could fit five other stadiums inside
the superdome and the fans were just
everywhere there's so much
anticipation and joy and angst and
suffering and happiness and joy and
those all right there and then at the
very end of the game chocolate peanut
butter love makes a couple of brilliant
offensive plays and north carolina wins
the game and it's like you're writing
this story you're making the movie it's
all right there you're creating it you
think it's all scripted and then
somebody else comes in and writes the
ending to it oh my gosh what a game what
a moment what a scene for the rest of my
life rich i will be able to say
that i was there
i was there
and i saw it all and to see how happy
all the winners were and to see how sad
all the losers that's what makes our
life so great yes it's sport yes it's a
platform yes it's a game but it means so
much to all of us and to have the fans
right there and one of the things that
that goes on in these moments
at the highest level
you have to learn to embrace and love
pressure and risk and doubt and
uncertainty because you never know how
these things are going to play out i
mean it it's like you know a bicycle
ride it's like going to a grateful dead
concert it's like life itself
you never know what's going to happen
and you better be ready for every
eventuality and these guys it's going to
be tough as can be for north carolina to
come back from that because
generally what happens in these games is
that the team that plays the best on
saturday night which was kansas kansas
is not on fire and obashi is just
lighting it up out there david mccormick
has never played better in his life
everybody jalen wilson christian brown
mitch lightfoot dejuan harris these guys
are all playing great the only guy that
didn't play well for kansas on saturday
night randy martin which is a good sign
for kansas because he can come back now
he'll be on the edge but
generally who plays best on saturday
night does not play best on monday
nights but the problem for north
carolina rich is that
they put so much into that game and they
were celebrating at the end of that game
as if it was
the championship and you cannot get back
up for the championship
until you come down and hopefully
they've been able to come down because
injury is significant here if i'm bill
self if i'm kansas i just say okay look
the story line is north carolina because
they just beat coach k and they just
beat duke and that was the whole deal
coming in here
we cannot look back we cannot hold back
they're going to be emotionally tired
caleb love and rj davis leaky black they
can play all day long and and never have
any sort of problems physically brady
manic and armando become with his ankle
they're not in that same situation here
so if you're kansas your mindset is we
are gonna run and we are gonna run and
we are gonna run and we are not gonna
stop and at some point
they're gonna wear down
north carolina does not have the depth
but the stars for kansas
they have to bring it and you can't come
out you don't get a championship by sort
of like hanging around and hope hope
that the other team is gonna not get it
done if your success is based on the
failures of others that's not what
championships are all about no so these
guys from kansas and the historical
ties in between these two schools and
the backgrounds of these two states
where the
you know james naismith and john
mcclendon and bob mcadoo who's got a son
on the north carolina team and they got
somebody named puff on the team
like such a wonderful story for
everything i love underdogs you know i
do not have a personal base i love
kansas basketball i love what bill self
does i i love the transition that he
made from the flogging teams to the up
and down yeah let's get going let's have
let's have tons of guys like scottie
pippen and michael jordan and all these
guys who can really run it really fly
we'll be in perfect condition we're just
going to push the pace all the time and
then the north carolina tradition with
all the remarkable players billy
cunningham bob mcadoo michael jordan sam
perkins james worthy all these legends
and the champions and the coaches and
you know and
and the fact that roy williams you know
from asheville played at north carolina
coached at kansas coached in north
carolina
this game tonight bill self and huber
davis this is the first time ever in the
history of the championship game that
the coaches are both successors of the
same person
that's interesting then you've got larry
brown who who played at unc played for
frank maguire and dean smith coached at
kansas for five years won the
championship with danny manning and
danny's part of our westwood one
coverage and it's just absolutely
incredible and dean smith who was born
in kansas died in north carolina played
at kansas for fall gallon won the ncaa
championship in 1952 the year i was born
he was a coaching assistant at ku before
he goes to north carolina
so this is just the harmonic convergence
of all things perfection and now
now it's up to the players and i love i
love the demeanor of the coaches and i
love the fans and their passion you know
this rock chalk jayhawks stuff whatever
that means i'm just not quite sure and
you got all these guys just gonna be
flying in from around the world and the
the challenge for all of us yes on this
championship moment it is is to bring it
back up to where it was because that
game of forever on saturday night
that will be forever ingrained in our
sight and that level that level of play
the level of intensity the level of
commitment and sacrifice and discipline
and honor and mental acuity and
emotional passion that is hard to
duplicate
as are you bill as are you bill walton
you were i i've uh god i just i honestly
i just love listening to you i love your
passion i love everything about it and
and you know in the couple minutes i
have left with you man i broke your car
one day in my life i'm gonna make it and
i'm gonna show up at your house
[Music]
and i'm gonna and i'm gonna i'm gonna
give you a brand new tesla no no no no i
don't need a car
it's just a it's just it was just a rear
it was just a rear windshield it's no
big deal it's already been replaced it
stopped it's the christmas i'm a man of
i'm a man of
duty i'm a man of obligation i know that
i'm a man of responsibility so
i i carry the heavy burden of destroying
your life no stop
you're the best man you're the best bill
so listen in the in the cup i love
championship days in the last two
minutes i have to go in in the last few
minutes i have with you here you're the
perfect person to ask uh
you know um the conversation about coach
k and better than wooden all-time great
woodens too he's now one or wooden's one
and two what do you think of when you
hear that conversation the question's
about i was there the day
that john wooden was named the greatest
coach ever not the greatest basketball
coach not the greatest college coach but
the greatest coach ever
and the guys behind are more vince
lombardi bear bryant phil jackson don
schuler and red auerbach and most of
those guys were mad as can be
particularly phil about being where they
were on the list and then when red found
out that he was behind phil uh
from inside his coffin let me out of
here
[Laughter]
john wooden's remarks were along these
lines
this is a very nice thing that you guys
say about me but
there is no way that anyone can ever
accurately say who the best is
what are the measurements what are the
standards
and then coach wood took a pause and he
said
i will acknowledge and accept that i'm
among the best
and then he transferred it again he said
i made a mistake with the pyramid of
success and i want to apologize for that
because i left the word love out of the
pyramid of success and love is the most
powerful and important word in our
language and culture until the
until the
power of love supersedes the love of
power we have no chance at success of
moving forward
and then he closed it when he said i
looked around the room he said i also
want to apologize
to everyone in this room and say i'm
sorry
and that i have not been able to do more
to help you
coach wooden lived a life of service to
others coach wooden's life
changed he was the first great player in
the history of basketball he got hurt he
could no longer play as that happens to
everybody he made a transition he became
this remarkable coach i have i don't
believe that he knows or he knew how
great a coach he was and how incredibly
important he was in in enabling us to
shape our lives mike schwebski like
vince lombardi bear bryant phil jackson
don shula
and red auerbach he's among the best and
rich how many children do you have we
have six children three we have 14
grandchildren and when somebody asks me
who's the best
i just say i love them all and i'm happy
and privileged honored and most
fortunate to
to be a parent to be a grandparent to be
a husband to be a houseboy to be someone
who's able to
be part of something really special the
way i've been here all this weekend in
new orleans mostly though i am grateful
that rich eisen still takes my
calls no pastor i ruined his tesla
i love you bill walton have a great time
tonight man i said what a game westwood
one two tonight it's all right there how
can we duplicate the game of forever
let's go let's give it a try you can't
finish what you don't start it's going
to take everything that we have let's go
take care
of peril you've been suitably warned be
in town early yeah new orleans jimmy
buffett grateful dead john fogarty
neville brothers andrews osborne
nikolaiko toots and the metals leon
russell dr john let's rock let's play
put the ball in the air put me in coach
i'm ready i love rich ice and i love
westwood one
have a great time tonight bill we'll be
listening you're the best thanks for the
call
out there he goes he's out he's out loud
that was
incredible wow
whoa so if you have your bill walton
bingo card oh my god you know at the
middle of the bingo card is
is either grateful dead or john wooden
yeah always okay i think at this point
it's the dead it's okay let's just
assume it's grateful dead
have this bingo unbelievable i have the
bingo of
jamba juice mookie blaylock grateful
dead
pearl jam dan pastorini bingo
that's the five
here we go well we got a whole bunch of
new drops on that one hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here